- Ласкаво просимо назад до курсу
«Розуміння квантової інформації та обчислень».
Мене звуть John Watrous, я технічний директор
з освіти IBM Quantum.
Це третій урок серії. У перших двох уроках ми говорили про основи
квантової інформації.
Спочатку про окремі системи в ізоляції, а потім про множинні системи.
Ми також обговорили вимірювання
у стандартному базисі та унітарні операції як в одиночних, так і
в багатосистемних умовах.
У цьому уроці ми введемо
модель quantum circuit, яка дає нам стандартний спосіб описувати квантові обчислення,
і ми також можемо використовувати quantum circuits для опису квантових протоколів та інших видів взаємодії між кількома квантовими пристроями.
Окрім quantum circuits, ми також обговоримо деякі
важливі математичні концепції, пов'язані з квантовою інформацією,
і ми використаємо їх, щоб спостерігати
декілька фундаментальних обмежень квантової інформації та того, що ми можемо робити з quantum circuits.
Це добре підготує нас до
наступного уроку, де ми побачимо кілька
дуже важливих прикладів, і це завершить
першу одиницю серії
про основи квантової інформації.
Ось огляд уроку. Ми почнемо з моделі quantum circuit і побачимо, як вона працює.
Потім ми поговоримо про
надзвичайно важливе поняття скалярного добутку, а також ортонормальності та проекцій,
які пов'язані зі скалярними добутками. Ми не обговорювали ці речі
в перших двох уроках, тому що нам справді не
потрібно було, але тепер потрібно.
Скалярні добутки надають нам
математичний інструмент, без якого ми просто не можемо обійтись.
Ми просто не просунемось далеко в розумінні квантової інформації та
обчислень без скалярних добутків.
А в третій частині уроку ми розглянемо
кілька важливих обмежень квантової інформації.
Зрештою, те, що ми хочемо зробити, — це досліджувати цікаві
речі, які ми можемо робити з квантовою інформацією, але щоб робити це ефективно,
нам потрібно знати про деякі
речі, які ми не можемо робити.
Зокрема, ми обговоримо
поняття глобальної фази та чому глобальні фази несуттєві.
Ми побачимо формулювання
теореми про заборону клонування, яка говорить нам, що квантові стани не можна копіювати в загальному випадку, і ми побачимо, що два квантові стани
не можуть бути абсолютно
розрізнені один від одного, якщо вони не ортогональні, що є фундаментальним
обмеженням, про яке слід знати.
Перша тема уроку —
модель quantum circuit, яка є моделлю обчислення,
що надає нам спосіб
описувати квантові обчислення.
Модель quantum circuit базується
на більш загальному понятті в комп'ютерних науках — circuit, і можна визначити багато
різних моделей обчислення
на основі цього загального поняття.
Основна ідея полягає в тому, що
circuit складається з дротів, які переносять інформацію, та gates, які представляють операції,
що застосовуються до
інформації, яку переносять дроти.
Термін circuit насправді
дещо дивна назва для такого роду моделі,
тому що слово circuit
зазвичай відноситься до
кругового шляху певного роду.
Але коли ми говоримо про circuits
як про моделі обчислень, ми зазвичай говоримо
про ациклічні circuits,
де кругові шляхи не допускаються.
Якщо бути точнішим, для
цілей цієї серії ми вимагатимемо, щоб
інформація завжди рухалась зліва направо в будь-якому circuit.
Тому, якщо хочеш,
можеш думати про circuits як про описи послідовностей операцій, де час іде зліва направо.
Ось приклад булевого circuit, де дроти несуть двійкові
значення — нуль або одиницю,
а gates представляють
операції булевої логіки.
Дроти представлені лініями, і тут у нас є два вхідних
біти, позначені X та Y,
і якщо ми хочемо знати,
що circuit робить при певному виборі вхідних даних, ми поширюємо значення на
дротах зліва направо,
залежно від дій,
які gates здійснюють на значеннях, що
несуть дроти.
Так, наприклад, ми можемо
поглянути на те, що відбувається, коли починаємо з верхнього вхідного дроту, встановленого в значення один, і нижнього вхідного дроту,
встановленого в значення нуль.
Ці два вхідних дроти ведуть
до цих двох точок прямо тут, які представляють операції розгалуження, що означає, що значення копіюється,
щоб воно могло передаватись
далі вздовж кількох дротів.
Тож якщо ми це зробимо, то ці
два дроти приймають значення один, яке збігається з цією одиницею, а ці два дроти приймають значення нуль,
яке збігається з цим нулем.
Тут у нас є gate NOT, що
позначається символом логічного заперечення, тому
значення на виході — нуль,
що є логічним запереченням одиниці. І аналогічно, значення
на виході цього gate — одиниця, яка є
логічним запереченням нуля.
Ці два gates є AND gates,
цей gate є OR gate, і якщо ми продовжимо
і поширимо значення
WEBVTT
через circuit, оцінюючи
gates відповідним чином, то побачимо, що кінцеве значення
на цьому дроті тут — одиниця.
Тож весь circuit описує
послідовність операцій, що складаються, як показує малюнок, і ми отримуємо функцію
від двох бітів до одного біта
в цьому конкретному випадку. Але загалом може бути будь-яка кількість
вхідних і вихідних бітів.
Цей конкретний circuit обчислює виключне АБО двох вхідних бітів, тому вихід дорівнює одиниці
тоді і тільки тоді, коли рівно
один з двох вхідних бітів встановлений в одиницю, а інший — в нуль, але це не так
важливо, це просто приклад.
Базовим фактом про булеві circuits є те, що будь-яка функція від будь-якої кількості бітів до будь-якої кількості бітів може бути обчислена
деяким булевим circuit, хоча іноді тобі може знадобитися
дуже великий circuit для обчислення функції,
яка тебе цікавить.
Існують інші стилі, що
використовуються для опису circuits.
Наприклад, цей малюнок
представляє точно той самий circuit, що й раніше, використовуючи стиль, що, мабуть, більш типовий
в електротехніці, де є умовні позначення форм, що представляють різні gates.
Ми не будемо використовувати
цей конкретний стиль, але ми введемо
деякі власні символи для різних quantum gates, таких як Hadamard gates,
Controlled NOT gates,
Toffoli gates тощо.
До речі, тут ми можемо побачити походження
терміну circuit.
В контексті електротехніки цілком природно
думати про електрику, що циркулює через circuit.
Але в цій серії ми говоримо не
про електрику, що рухається через circuits, а про інформацію,
що рухається через circuits.
І знову ж таки, для нас вони завжди будуть ациклічними, де інформація
рухається зліва направо.
Ось інший приклад
іншого типу circuit, що називається арифметичним circuit.
Цього разу дроти зберігають числа, а gates представляють
арифметичні операції, такі як додавання та множення.
Тут ти можеш побачити приклад
арифметичного circuit.
Не важливо для цього уроку, що він робить, це просто приклад, який
покликаний передати ідею про те, що існують різні
поняття circuits.
Ми також можемо думати про
circuits, що включають випадковість, наприклад, де gates представляють
імовірнісні операції, і якщо захочеш,
ти, напевно, міг би просидіти весь день, вигадуючи нові моделі обчислень, засновані на понятті circuits.
У моделі quantum circuit
дроти представляють qubits, а gates представляють як унітарні операції, так і вимірювання.
Ось дуже простий приклад
quantum circuit.
У цьому circuit є лише один qubit, який представлений
горизонтальною лінією, а gates, що
позначені квадратами,
представляють унітарні операції, що виконуються на цьому qubit.
Тож у цьому конкретному прикладі
вимірювань немає.
Якщо ми хочемо дати
qubit ім'я, наприклад X, ми можемо вказати це на діаграмі, поставивши X прямо
тут, це необов'язково.
Так само, як і для булевого circuit трохи раніше, ми можемо думати про цей circuit
як про послідовність операцій, де час
іде зліва направо.
Тож ми починаємо з X,
застосовуємо перший gate, яким є Hadamard gate,
за яким іде S gate,
потім ще один Hadamard
gate, і нарешті T gate.
Ми бачили ці операції
наприкінці першого уроку, і тут ти можеш побачити
їх матричні описи.
Тож коли ми виконуємо ці
чотири операції по порядку, тобто спочатку H, потім
S, потім знову H, а потім T,
комбінована операція задається
цим добутком прямо тут, пам'ятаючи, що порядок
по суті обертається
як ми обговорювали в першому уроці. Якщо ми виконуємо матричне множення, отримуємо цю матрицю прямо тут,
і тому дія circuit
на qubit X описується цією унітарною матрицею.
Іноді ми хочемо явно вказати в діаграмі quantum circuit,
який вхід ми подаємо, і можемо зробити це так, як ти бачиш тут.
У цьому випадку ми подаємо
Ket 0 у circuit.
Це доволі поширено. Ми часто беремо Ket 0 як
початковий стан qubit, але це не обов'язково.
Ми також могли б розглянути
застосування circuit до іншого стану.
Якщо захочемо, ми також можемо
вказати вихідний стан, який отримаємо, ось так.
Ось ще один приклад, де
цього разу у нас є два qubits на ім'я X та Y, як
видно на діаграмі.
Тут у нас є Hadamard gate, який застосовується до qubit Y, за яким іде gate, позначений
цим символом прямо тут,
яким є Controlled NOT gate. Ми говорили про
операцію Controlled NOT у попередньому уроці,
і тут на цій діаграмі ми
можемо бачити, що керуючий qubit — це Y, що позначається
маленьким закрашеним колом,
а цільовий qubit — це X, що позначається великим колом з тим, що виглядає як знак плюс у ньому.
Це трохи нагадує
символ виключного АБО, тому має сенс.
WEBVTT
Ти можеш уявити, що який би
класичний стан не зберігався в Y, він XOR-иться на qubit X.
І просто для ясності, ось діаграма, що
показує дію цього gate на стани стандартного базису,
де ми припускаємо, що A
та B є двійковими значеннями.
Для інших станів дія визначається
лінійністю, як завжди.
Тепер, перш ніж йти далі, буде корисно
явно сформулювати конвенцію, якої ми будемо дотримуватись щодо порядку qubits
у діаграмах quantum circuit на кшталт цієї.
І конвенція полягає в тому, що
упорядкування знизу вгору в діаграмі quantum circuit еквівалентно упорядкуванню зліва направо
як у кортежі або тензорному добутку.
Це конвенція, якої ми будемо
дотримуватись у серії, і це також конвенція,
що використовується в Qiskit.
Тож для цього конкретного circuit тут ми думаємо про нього як про
діючий на пару qubits X, Y,
X стоїть першим, тому що він знизу, а Y стоїть останнім або другим у цьому випадку, тому що він зверху.
Спосіб уявити це
візуально, якщо це допомагає, — уявити поворот
цього circuit за годинниковою стрілкою так, щоб входи були зверху,
а виходи — знизу, і порядок
qubits буде правильним.
Іноді цей порядок збиває людей з пантелику, тому просто обов'язково пам'ятай
про цю конвенцію.
Тож коли ми думаємо про дію, яку описує цей circuit, спочатку у нас є
Hadamard gate, застосований до Y,
а потім Controlled NOT
gate на двох qubits, де Y є керуючим,
а X — цільовим.
Якщо ми хочемо записати унітарну матрицю, що описує комбіновану
дію цих двох gates, ми можемо це зробити.
Спочатку ми розглядаємо Hadamard gate на Y.
Ми застосовуємо Hadamard gate до Y і нічого не робимо з X, що еквівалентно
виконанню операції тотожності на X.
І тому дія Hadamard gate на обидва qubits разом задається
тензорним добутком матриці тотожності та
матриці, що представляє
операцію Hadamard на Y.
Це виглядає ось так, пам'ятаючи нашу
конвенцію, що X стоїть першим, а Y другим, тому це
тотожність, тензорно перемножена з H.
Потім ми застосовуємо
операцію Controlled NOT, яка має це матричне
представлення, і знову це узгоджується з нашою конвенцією.
Другий qubit Y є керуючим, а перший qubit X є цільовим.
Не бійся зупинити відео і перевірити, що це має сенс, і я перестану нагадувати тобі про це.
Ти можеш зупиняти ці відео, повертатись і дивитись частини
стільки разів, скільки захочеш, регулювати швидкість відтворення, використовувати їх у будь-який
спосіб, який найкраще підходить тобі.
Тож, коли ми складаємо
дві операції разом, комбінована дія описується
цим добутком прямо тут,
і ці дві матриці
множаться в такому порядку, тому що Hadamard виконується першим, а Controlled NOT
виконується другим,
і знову це узгоджується
з тим, що ми обговорювали в першому уроці, де порядок
по суті обертається.
Якщо ми виконаємо матричне множення, отримаємо цю матрицю прямо тут.
І тепер ми можемо прочитати з цієї матриці, що circuit робить зі
станами стандартного базису.
Якщо ми запускаємо circuit на вході 0, 0, тобто Ket 0 для першого qubit і Ket 0 для другого qubit,
результатом є стан Bell Phi+, що ми бачимо по
першому стовпцю матриці.
Якщо ми подаємо 0, 1, отримуємо стан Phi-, один нуль дає нам стан Si+,
а 1, 1 дає нам не Psi-, а -1 X Psi-.
Знак мінус тут
насправді несуттєвий. Якщо ти не хочеш, щоб він тут був, ти міг би виконати операцію swap
на двох qubits,
щоб позбутися його, і ти
не порушиш те, що сталося з першими трьома станами стандартного базису.
Але для цього прикладу
це справді не важливо.
Отже, підсумовуючи, circuit має таку дію прямо тут на стани стандартного базису.
Коли ти думаєш про
те, що робить конкретний circuit, тобі не потрібно проходити
через перетворення в матриці та множити їх разом,
ти також можеш відслідкувати
дію, яку circuit має на конкретні стани, і в багатьох випадках це буде
кращим варіантом.
Наприклад, у цьому прикладі ми можемо побачити, що circuit
робить зі станом 0, 0, вивчаючи дію gates.
Початковий стан, який
ми назвали Pi zero тут, просто щоб уникнути назви,
яка плуталась би зі станами Bell, дорівнює 0, 0.
Ми застосовуємо Hadamard gate і отримуємо стан 0+, який можемо розгорнути ось так,
а потім операція Controlled NOT переводить цей стан у стан Phi+, що ми бачимо, думаючи
про дію, яку Controlled NOT має на
стани стандартного базису,
і ти можеш зробити те ж саме
для інших трьох станів стандартного базису або будь-якого
іншого стану.
Ми також можемо включати класичні біти в діаграми quantum circuit.
Вони позначаються
подвійними лініями, як ти бачиш на цій діаграмі.
Тобто A та B є класичними бітами, а X та Y є qubits.
WEBVTT
Ми маємо ті ж два унітарних gates, що й у попередньому прикладі, і ці символи прямо тут представляють вимірювання у стандартному базисі.
Зокрема, після того, як виконуються дві
унітарних операції, вимірювання у стандартному базисі
виконується на Y,
і результат перезаписується
в класичний біт B, і аналогічно X вимірюється і результат записується в біт A.
Тут ти можеш бачити, що qubits X та Y продовжують існувати після вимірювання.
Доволі поширено,
однак, що нас не дуже цікавлять qubits
після їх вимірювання.
Іноді нас цікавить лише
результат вимірювання. І в такому випадку ми можемо використовувати скорочений
стиль, що ти бачиш тут,
де вимірювання приймають qubits на вхід і видають класичні біти на виход.
Розуміння тут таке, що
після вимірювання qubits вони просто відкидаються або ігноруються, а класичний результат
вимірювання переноситься далі.
Тепер у міру продовження серії ми будемо бачити багато
прикладів quantum circuits, і вони, як правило,
будуть набагато складнішими, ніж дуже прості
приклади, які ми щойно бачили.
Як я вже згадував, різні символи використовуються
для різних gates.
Одно-qubitні gates зазвичай
просто записуються як квадрати з літерою, що вказує,
яка це операція.
Іноді ці різні
gates кодуються кольором для позначення різних речей, але
поки що ми ігноруємо це.
Ми вже бачили
Controlled NOT gate.
Swap gates позначаються
так, як ти бачиш тут, а Toffoli gates і Fredkin gates
позначаються так, як ти бачиш тут.
Пам'ятай, що Toffoli gate — це контрольований Controlled NOT gate, а Fredkin gate — це
контрольований swap gate.
Тож ці символи
узгоджуються з ідеєю, що керуючий qubit
позначається суцільним колом з лінією, що з'єднує його
з gate, яким він управляє.
Загалом, керуючі qubits
не обов'язково мають бути зверху, і ці gates не
обов'язково мають діяти на сусідні qubits, тобто ці gates
можуть розтягуватись через
інші qubits, на які вони не діють, і ми побачимо це
в майбутніх уроках.
Ще одна річ, яку ми часто робимо при використанні моделі quantum circuit, — це розглядати довільні унітарні операції
на будь-якій кількості qubits
як ніби вони є одиничними gates, як ти бачиш тут.
Просто малюючи прямокутник з міткою, що відповідає
тій унітарній операції, що це є.
У цьому випадку це деяка
унітарна операція U.
Звичайно, ми не знаємо,
що таке U із цієї діаграми, ми повинні припустити, що
U визначено якимось чином, або що ми розглядаємо деяку довільну
унітарну операцію U, можливо. Наприклад, може бути таке,
що ми просто хочемо думати про U як про підпрограму в
інтересах ясності.
Ми також використовуємо цей запис,
що ти бачиш тут, для операції controlled U,
де керуючий qubit позначається суцільним колом,
як і раніше.
Отже, це коротке введення
до моделі quantum circuit. І як я вже сказав, ми побачимо ще багато
прикладів quantum circuits
у міру продовження серії.
У наступній частині уроку ми поглянемо на
скалярні добутки, ортонормальність і проекції, що є дуже важливими поняттями
в квантовій інформації та обчисленнях.
Почнемо зі скалярних добутків.
Пам'ятай, що коли ми
використовуємо нотацію Дірака, Ket — це вектор-стовпець,
а Bra — це вектор-рядок,
і зокрема, вектор
Bra, що відповідає даному вектору-стовпцю, є спряженою транспонованою
цього вектора-стовпця.
Тож для цього вектора прямо тут ми отримуємо відповідний вектор Bra, транспонуючи вектор
як матрицю,
що рівносильно укладанню його набік, а потім беремо комплексне спряження кожного з елементів.
Тепер припустимо, що у нас є два Kets з однаковою кількістю елементів, ось так.
Якщо ми утворимо цей дужковий запис прямо тут, що просто означає, що
ми беремо добуток Bra і Ket,
як якщо б вони були матрицями,
то отримаємо цей вираз,
що ти бачиш тут, який є скаляром, або іншими словами комплексним числом.
Це значення називається скалярним
добутком цих двох векторів.
Ти також можеш думати про скалярні добутки в термінах векторів
форми, що ти бачиш тут, де вектори виражені
як лінійні комбінації
векторів стандартного базису.
Скалярний добуток цих векторів визначається так само, як
і раніше, Bra Psi помножене на Ket Phi, що ми можемо виразити
як добуток ось так.
І якщо ми обчислимо і спростимо, отримаємо цей вираз прямо тут для скалярного добутку, що аналогічний тому, що ми мали раніше,
за винятком того, що цього разу ми
беремо суму по елементах нашої множини класичних станів, якою в цьому конкретному випадку є сигма.
Ось приклад, покликаний дати тобі геометричне уявлення про
те, як скалярні добутки працюють.
Тут я намалював коло
у двовимірному просторі, що відповідає qubit, і якщо ми обмежимо свою увагу
векторами з дійсними числовими елементами, то можемо намалювати їх як точки на цій площині.
WEBVTT
Нехай Phi буде
цим вектором прямо тут.
Це одиничний вектор, що ми можемо бачити, обчислюючи евклідову норму, і ось що представляє це коло,
це всі одиничні вектори
з дійсними числовими елементами.
Нехай також Psi буде
цим вектором прямо тут, який знову ж таки є одиничним вектором.
Це насправді мінус-стан, але тут ми просто називаємо його Psi.
Якщо ми обчислимо скалярний
добуток цих двох векторів, отримаємо один мінус квадратний корінь з трьох, поділений на два, помножений на корінь з двох,
що приблизно дорівнює -1/4.
Значення цього скалярного добутку дорівнює косинусу кута
між двома векторами, що ти можеш бачити тут на малюнку.
Це загалом справедливо для одиничних векторів. Якщо у нас є два одиничних вектори і вони обидва мають дійсні числові елементи,
то скалярний добуток між ними дорівнює косинусу
кута між ними.
Зокрема, якщо скалярний
добуток дорівнює нулю, як у цьому прикладі, де ми змінили Psi на
цей стан прямо тут,
то два вектори мають бути
під кутом 90 градусів один до одного.
Все це узагальнюється на
вектори в будь-якому вимірі, до речі, якщо
елементи є дійсними числами, це не тільки для двовимірних векторів.
Якщо ми маємо комплексні числові елементи, картина вже не дуже
працює, але тим не менш скалярний добуток настільки ж корисний, як ми побачимо.
Скалярний добуток має деякі
дуже важливі властивості, і ми витратимо кілька хвилин, щоб спостерігати деякі з цих властивостей зараз.
Перша — це зв'язок
між скалярним добутком та евклідовою нормою.
Якщо ми беремо скалярний добуток
будь-якого вектора з самим собою, отримуємо евклідову норму в квадраті.
Тому ми можемо альтернативно сказати, що евклідова норма вектора дорівнює квадратному
кореню зі скалярного добутку
цього вектора з самим собою. Це не збіг, це
фундаментальний зв'язок, і тут ми бачимо, що якщо б у нас не було
комплексних спряжених у визначенні скалярного добутку, то ця формула
вже не була б правдивою, і у нас не було б такого корисного поняття
з цим фундаментальним зв'язком
з евклідовою нормою.
Далі, скалярний добуток
є спряжено симетричним, що означає: якщо ми міняємо
порядок двох аргументів, то значення, яке ми отримуємо для
скалярного добутку, спрягається.
Це виражається
цим рівнянням прямо тут, і досить просто зрозуміти, чому це відбувається для цих двох виразів
для скалярного добутку двох векторів у двох можливих порядках.
Скалярний добуток лінійний
у другому аргументі. Зокрема, якщо ми визначаємо вектор Phi як цю лінійну
комбінацію двох векторів,
Phi один і Phi два, то скалярний добуток
будь-якого вектора Psi з Phi є тією ж лінійною комбінацією
двох скалярних добутків,
і це досить безпосередньо випливає з того факту, що матричне множення є лінійним.
А також у нас є те, що скалярний
добуток є спряжено лінійним у першому аргументі, що ти можеш бачити, вираженим тут.
Якщо Psi — це ця лінійна
комбінація векторів, то якщо ми беремо скалярний
добуток Psi та Phi,
то Bra Psi стає цим вектором, що ти бачиш тут, де ми беремо комплексне
спряження від beta один і beta два,
і тому це результат, і ось що
мається на увазі під спряженою лінійністю.
І остання властивість скалярного добутку, яку я хочу згадати, — це
надзвичайно корисна нерівність Коші-Шварца.
Для будь-яких двох векторів Psi і Phi, абсолютне значення скалярного добутку ніколи не може бути більшим за добуток евклідових норм
двох векторів. І більше того, єдиний спосіб, щоб дві
сторони нерівності були рівними, полягає в тому, щоб два
вектори були лінійно залежними,
що означає, що один з них дорівнює деякому скаляру, помноженому на інший.
Це насправді одна з
найбільш широко використовуваних нерівностей у всій математиці, і
ми використовуємо її знову і знову, коли говоримо про
квантову інформацію,
тому дуже добре знати про неї.
Далі ми поговоримо про
поняття ортогональності та ортонормальності, які
пов'язані зі скалярними добутками,
і зокрема зі
скалярними добутками векторів, що дорівнюють нулю.
Якщо бути точним, якщо у нас є
два вектори Psi і Phi, ми кажемо, що вони ортогональні,
якщо їх скалярний добуток
дорівнює нулю. І спосіб думати
про ортогональні вектори інтуїтивно полягає в тому, що вони
знаходяться під прямим кутом один до одного,
або альтернативно, що вони
перпендикулярні один одному.
Люди іноді використовують термін ортогональний для позначення речей, які
не мають нічого спільного одна з одною, наприклад кажучи, що одне питання
є ортогональним до іншого,
але це, очевидно, доволі неформально і не дуже значущо
в математичному сенсі, але зв'язок зрозумілий, якщо думати про ортогональні
вектори як такі, що вказують
не в протилежних напрямках, а в зовсім різних напрямках, наприклад, північ проти заходу.
Якщо у нас є множина векторів, ми кажемо, що множина є ортогональною, якщо будь-які два різних вектори,
вибраних з цієї множини,
обов'язково ортогональні один одному, що ми можемо виразити
ось так,
WEBVTT
Ортонормальна множина —
це просто ортогональна множина одиничних векторів.
Вектори в ортогональних
множинах не обов'язково мають бути одиничними векторами, і насправді ти міг би
навіть мати нульовий вектор
як елемент ортогональної множини, але в ортонормальній множині кожен вектор повинен бути одиничним вектором
на додаток до
вимоги, що множина є ортогональною.
З огляду на те, що ми знаємо про взаємозв'язок між скалярним добутком
та евклідовою нормою, ми можемо виразити цю
умову досить стисло,
як ти бачиш тут.
І нарешті, ортонормальний базис — це просто ортонормальна
множина, що утворює базис для того векторного простору,
про який ми говоримо.
Наприклад, якщо ми беремо будь-яку
множину класичних станів сигма і думаємо про множину
всіх векторів стандартного базису,
ми бачимо, що це ортонормальна множина, і насправді це ортонормальний базис для простору всіх векторів, елементи яких відповідають
цій множині класичних станів сигма.
Це все одиничні вектори і
вони попарно ортогональні, тому це ортонормальна множина.
і оскільки це ще й базис, ми маємо, що це ортонормальний базис.
Ортонормальні множини
завжди лінійно незалежні, до речі, тому в будь-який момент, коли у тебе є ортонормальна множина, вона завжди буде ортонормальним
базисом для деякого підпростору,
але в цьому випадку у нас є базис для всього простору, з яким ми працюємо.
Інший приклад — це множина,
що містить Ket+ та Ket-.
Ці два вектори ортогональні, їх скалярний добуток дорівнює нулю.
і вони обидва є одиничними векторами і вони охоплюють
двовимірний простір векторів, що відповідає одному qubit, тому вони утворюють ортонормальний
базис для цього простору.
Інший приклад — це базис Bell, який є ортонормальним базисом для простору всіх
чотиривимірних векторів, що відповідають двом qubits.
Множина, що містить Ket 0
та Ket+, навпаки, не є ортогональною множиною, тому що скалярний добуток між
цими векторами ненульовий.
Вони обидва є одиничними векторами, і це базис для векторного простору, що відповідає qubit, але в нас немає ортогональності.
Ось зручний факт про ортонормальні множини, яким ми будемо користуватись час від часу.
Припустимо, що у нас є деяка
ортонормальна множина векторів, зокрема, припустимо,
що у нас є M векторів у цій множині, від Psi один до Psi M,
де ми припускаємо, що ці вектори взяті з деякого N-вимірного векторного простору, або іншими словами, кожен з
векторів має M елементів.
Як я вже згадував, ортонормальні множини завжди
лінійно незалежні, тому M не може бути більшим за N,
але M може бути меншим за N, і це той випадок, який
нас цікавить.
І що стверджує цей факт —
що якщо M менше ніж N, то завжди можна
додати додаткові вектори
до множини, з якої ми почали, щоб отримати
ортонормальний базис для нашого простору.
Якщо бути точним, обов'язково
мають існувати вектори від Psi M+1 до Psi N, так що вся колекція
утворює ортонормальний базис.
Тож ти ніколи не можеш зайти в глухий кут, так би мовити, якось вибравши
ортонормальну множину векторів, яку не можна розширити до
утворення ортонормального базису.
Іноді ти можеш просто подивитись
на множину, з якої починаєш, і зрозуміти, як розширити її до ортонормального базису, але альтернатива, що завжди працює,
полягає у використанні процедури, відомої як процес ортонормалізації Грама-Шмідта для побудови цих векторів.
Я не пояснюватиму цю
процедуру в цьому уроці або в цій серії, тому що специфіка
насправді не важлива для нас, але звісно ти можеш
знайти її, якщо тобі цікаво.
Це щось таке, що може
виконати комп'ютер, якщо це актуально, тому
тут немає творчості, це просто механічна процедура.
Одна з причин, чому це
такий зручний факт для нас, пов'язана з тісним зв'язком, що існує між ортонормальними
базисами та унітарними матрицями.
Зокрема, для будь-якої квадратної матриці U три умови, що ти бачиш тут, завжди еквівалентні,
тобто вони або всі правдиві, або всі хибні.
Перша умова говорить,
що U є унітарною матрицею, що означає, що як U кинджал помножене на U, так і U помножене на U кинджал обидва
рівні матриці тотожності.
Друга умова
говорить, що рядки U утворюють ортонормальний базис,
а третя умова говорить, що стовпці U
утворюють ортонормальний базис.
Насправді не так важко
зрозуміти, чому ця еквівалентність є правдивою.
Просто для простоти, розглянемо
матрицю U три на три, як ти бачиш тут, де елементи можуть бути будь-якими
комплексними числами на твій вибір.
Тут зліва я записав U спряжену транспоновану
просто для зручності.
Якщо ми утворимо три вектори
зі стовпців U, які тут названі Psi
один, Psi два та Psi три, то якщо ми беремо
добуток U кинджал і U,
можна перевірити, що кожен
елемент добутку задається скалярним добутком векторів, як ми бачимо тут у цьому патерні.
І тепер, коли ти думаєш про умову, що U є унітарною, що еквівалентно тому, що ця матриця дорівнює матриці тотожності,
ти бачиш, що це еквівалентно
тому, що три вектори утворюють ортонормальну множину.
Діагональні елементи всі
мають дорівнювати одиниці, тому це обов'язково одиничні вектори, а позадіагональні
елементи мають дорівнювати нулю,
тому це ортогональна множина векторів.
WEBVTT
Тож унітарність U еквівалентна тому, що стовпці утворюють ортонормальну множину,
і це має бути базисом, тому що кількість векторів у множині, яка в цьому випадку дорівнює трьом, збігається з розмірністю простору,
з яким ми працюємо. Ти можеш слідувати схожому аргументу для рядків замість стовпців, щоб прийти до висновку, що унітарність U еквівалентна
тому, що рядки утворюють ортонормальний базис.
Це не так акуратно, тому що нам доводиться робити поправку, щоб отримати комплексні спряження правильним чином, але ідея та сама.
Альтернативний спосіб зробити це, що є досить прямолінійним, полягає у тому, щоб довести, що матриця є унітарною тоді і тільки тоді, коли її транспонована є унітарною.
І тут я маю на увазі саме транспонування, а не спряжене транспонування.
Цілком тривіально з
визначення унітарних матриць, що спряжено транспонована
будь-якої унітарної матриці є унітарною,
але також справедливо, що транспонована будь-якої унітарної матриці є унітарною.
У будь-якому разі, ми маємо
еквівалентність між цими трьома умовами для будь-якої квадратної матриці U, і ми можемо поєднати цю еквівалентність
з фактом про
розширення ортонормальних множин до ортонормальних базисів, щоб знайти унітарні матриці,
які роблять цікаві речі
або задовольняють різні потреби, які ми можемо зустріти.
Зокрема, щоразу, коли у нас є ортонормальна множина з M векторів, завжди існуватиме унітарна матриця U,
перші M стовпців якої є векторами з цієї ортонормальної множини.
Решту стовпців
завжди можна заповнити так, щоб отримати унітарну матрицю, вибираючи їх так, щоб стовпці утворювали
ортонормальний базис. Це буде досить
зручним фактом для нас.
І ще одна тема для
цього розділу уроку — поняття проекції.
Квадратна матриця Pi
називається проекцією або матрицею проекції, якщо дві властивості,
що перераховані тут, обидві виконуються.
До речі, це велика Pi, це досить типовий вибір літери для позначення проекції.
Ми часто даємо такі типові назви об'єктам, наприклад матрицям, просто щоб зробити їх легшими для розпізнавання та тримати все в порядку,
але ти міг би використовувати будь-яку назву, яка тобі подобається. Тож перша умова полягає в тому, що Pi дорівнює своїй власній спряженій транспонованій.
Загалом, коли у нас є матриця, що дорівнює своїй власній
спряженій транспонованій, ми кажемо, що вона є ермітовою матрицею.
Тому першу умову можна альтернативно сформулювати як Pi є ермітовою.
Друга умова полягає в
тому, що якщо ми зводимо Pi у квадрат, тобто множимо Pi
само на себе, ми отримуємо Pi знову.
Тож зведення Pi у квадрат нічого з ним не робить.
Ідея проекції
інтуїтивно полягає в тому, що вона подібна за духом до проектування зображення на екран або опускання перпендикуляра на пряму
наприклад. Коли ти множиш
вектор на проекцію, те, що ти робиш, у певному сенсі
залишає частину його незміненою
і обнуляє решту.
Тож якщо ти застосовуєш
проекцію вдруге, вона нічого не робить, тому що
ти вже обнулив частину, яку проекція обнуляє.
Прикладом проекції
є ця матриця прямо тут для будь-якого вибору одиничного вектора Psi.
Ми можемо перевірити, що вона задовольняє
необхідним умовам, по одній.
Для першої ми обчислюємо
спряжену транспоновану, і це спряжена
транспонована добутку.
Тому ми можемо скористатись цією формулою прямо тут для спряженої транспонованої
добутку, щоб допомогти нам.
Те, що ти отримуєш, — це добуток
спряжено транспонованих, але порядок обертається.
Це відбувається через
частину транспонування.
Тож якщо ми застосуємо цю формулу, отримаємо це рівняння прямо тут, і потім можемо спростити, щоб
повернутися до вихідної матриці.
До речі, зауваж, що ми не використовували факт,
що Psi є одиничним вектором.
Тож насправді ця матриця є
ермітовою для будь-якого вектора Psi, не тільки для одиничних векторів.
А для другої умови ми зводимо Pi у квадрат і отримуємо
цей вираз прямо тут, і він дорівнює вихідній матриці цього разу,
тому що Psi є одиничним вектором, тому цей скалярний добуток
прямо тут дорівнює одиниці, і ось де припущення,
що Psi є одиничним вектором,
вступає в гру.
Ми можемо узагальнити цей приклад і почати з ортонормальної множини.
І якщо ми утворимо цю матрицю прямо тут, де ми підсумовуємо проекції, що відповідають окремим векторам, то отримаємо проекцію.
Тут на екрані ти бачиш обчислення, що це підтверджують, і я залишу тобі можливість
вивчити їх, якщо забажаєш.
І аналогічно першому прикладу,
саме у другій умові використовується ортонормальність
множини.
Те, що ця проекція робить, якщо
ти множиш її на вектор, — це проектує цей
вектор на підпростір, що охоплений цією множиною векторів,
що в абстрактному сенсі є
як опускання перпендикуляра до цього підпростору, і як тільки
ти в цьому підпросторі, проекція нічого не робить.
Тому матриці на кшталт цих є
прикладами проекцій, і тепер насправді ми вичерпали
всі можливості.
Кожна матриця проекції має таку форму для деякого вибору ортонормальної множини.
Нульова матриця є проекцією, тому нам слід обов'язково включити її, якщо ми хочемо отримати кожну проекцію.
WEBVTT
Тож просто щоб бути зрозумілим щодо цього, ми допускаємо
можливість того, що M дорівнює нулю, і це дає нам порожню суму,
яку ми можемо інтерпретувати як нульову матрицю.
Тепер, коли у нас є
концепція проекції, ми можемо визначити ширший клас квантових вимірювань, відомих як проекційні вимірювання.
Це не найзагальніше
поняття вимірювання, але воно суттєво ширше, ніж вимірювання у стандартному базисі,
і буде дуже
корисно включити його в наш опис
квантової інформації.
Проекційне вимірювання визначається будь-якою множиною проекцій,
що задовольняє умову, яку ти бачиш тут, — що проекції
у сумі дають матрицю тотожності.
Тут M може бути будь-яким
позитивним цілим числом, якщо тільки це все проекції і ця умова виконується,
колекція визначає
проекційне вимірювання.
Вимірювання, описане
такою колекцією, працює так, коли ти
вимірюєш будь-який квантовий стан Psi.
Спочатку ти отримуєш результат
від одного до M, де M — кількість проекцій.
Для кожного можливого результату K, імовірність отримати цей результат — це евклідова норма
в квадраті вектора, що ти отримуєш,
множачи S на Pi
K, K-ту проекцію.
Ми також можемо записати цю
величину так, як ти бачиш тут.
Ця рівність випливає зі зв'язку між евклідовою
нормою та скалярним добутком разом з фактом,
що Pi K є проекцією.
З другої форми, разом з умовою, що ми маємо на ці проекції, ми бачимо відразу, з лінійності, що наші імовірності
завжди будуть у сумі давати одиницю,
пам'ятаючи, що Psi
має бути одиничним вектором.
І по-друге, якщо ми
припускаємо, що отримали результат K, стан системи
колапсує до квантового стану, який ми отримуємо, нормуючи будь-який
вектор, отриманий проектуванням.
Ми розглянемо деякі
приклади за мить, але перш ніж це зробити, дозволь зауважити, що нам насправді не потрібно
нумерувати можливі
результати від одного до M. Ми можемо вибрати будь-які назви або символи для результатів.
Зокрема, якщо у нас є колекція проекцій, що позначені символами
з деякої множини гамма, скажімо,
і вони задовольняють ту
ж умову, що й раніше, — що вони у сумі
дають матрицю тотожності, то у нас є проекційне вимірювання,
що працює точно
так само, як і раніше.
Єдина відмінність тут полягає в тому, що ми дозволяємо
результатам вимірювання бути елементами цієї множини гамма, а не цілими числами від одного до M.
Як наш перший приклад
проекційного вимірювання, давай спостерігатимемо, що
вимірювання у стандартному базисі є проекційними вимірюваннями.
У цьому випадку множина
результатів вимірювання збігається з множиною класичних станів тієї системи, що вимірюється.
І множина проекцій,
що описує вимірювання, — це ця колекція прямо тут, якщо сигма —
множина класичних станів
нашої системи. Це все проекції,
і якщо ми їх підсумуємо, ми отримаємо матрицю тотожності, тому це дійсне проекційне вимірювання.
Щоб побачити, як це працює
трохи детальніше, припустимо, що у нас є
деякий довільний стан, записаний у формі,
що ти бачиш тут.
Імовірність того, що
вимірювання дасть результат A, відповідно до опису
з хвилину тому, — це це значення тут,
що дорівнює
абсолютному значенню в квадраті відповідного
елемента вектора Psi, що і є те, чого ми очікуємо.
За умови, що результат — A, стан системи стає таким, знову відповідно до
опису з хвилину тому.
Якщо ми спростимо, ми
не зовсім отримаємо стан, якого очікуємо, — Ket A.
Замість цього ми отримаємо Ket A,
помножений на скаляр, і зокрема, це скаляр, що має
абсолютне значення, рівне одиниці,
тому це комплексне число
на одиничному колі.
Це називається глобальною фазою, і ми обговоримо глобальні фази незабаром, але поки що, коротко кажучи, цей
стан еквівалентний Ket A.
Ця глобальна фаза насправді
не має жодного значення, і ми побачимо чому,
коли дійдемо до обговорення глобальних фаз.
Тож відклавши це питання про глобальні фази, яке ми обговоримо за мить, ми бачимо, що вимірювання у стандартному базисі
насправді є проекційними вимірюваннями. Як інший приклад, що є насправді розширенням
попереднього прикладу,
якщо ми виконуємо вимірювання у стандартному
базисі на системі X і нічого не робимо з системою Y, як ми обговорювали
в попередньому уроці,
це повністю еквівалентно
до вимірювання системи X, Y
з цим проекційним
вимірюванням прямо тут.
У нас є ці проекції, що відповідають класичним станам X, і ми беремо тензорний добуток з тотожністю на Y,
що відображає факт, що
ми нічого не робимо з Y.
Опис того, як
проекційні вимірювання працюють загалом, говорить нам,
що відбувається в цьому прикладі, і я залишу тобі
перевірити, що це насправді
повністю еквівалентно до того, що ми обговорювали в попередньому уроці.
Все це дуже добре, тому що цей опис проекційного
вимірювання є чистішим у певному сенсі, і ми бачимо, що він вписується в
цю більш загальну картину.
WEBVTT
Ось ще один приклад
проекційного вимірювання.
Це вимірювання двох qubits.
Для цього вимірювання
у нас є дві проекції і тому два можливих
результати, які є нулем і одиницею.
Проекції визначені
в термінах станів Bell, як ти бачиш тут.
Перша проекція —
на простір, що охоплений трьома симетричними станами Bell, а друга проекція — на одновимірний простір,
що охоплений станом Psi-, який є антисиметричним, або іншими словами тим,
на якому множиться
знак мінус, якщо ми
виконуємо операцію swap на двох qubits.
Ми побачимо пізніше в серії, чому це цікаве вимірювання.
Зараз це просто приклад,
що пов'язується з тим, що ми бачили раніше, —
з базисом Bell.
Одна остання примітка щодо проекційних вимірювань: кожного разу, коли у тебе є проекційне вимірювання, ти завжди можеш реалізувати це вимірювання
за допомогою унітарних операцій та
вимірювань у стандартному базисі.
Для цього конкретного прикладу
вимірювання, наприклад, ми можемо побудувати quantum circuit, що реалізує вимірювання,
як ти бачиш тут.
Ми уявляємо, що верхні
два qubits — це qubits, які ми вимірюємо цим проекційним вимірюванням, і те, що ми можемо зробити, — це
ввести новий qubit,
що починає ініціалізованим
у нульовий стан. Ми виконуємо Hadamard gate,
за яким іде Fredkin gate, а за ним ще один Hadamard gate,
і якщо ми вимірюємо цей нижній qubit за допомогою вимірювання у стандартному базисі, ефект буде точно таким, ніби ми виміряли верхні два qubits
з проекційним
вимірюванням із цього прикладу.
Ми отримаємо точно такі ж імовірності для двох результатів, і ефект, який вимірювання має на верхні два qubits,
буде теж однаковим.
Це аж ніяк не очевидно. Для того, щоб це побачити, потрібен аналіз, і цей аналіз тут не показаний.
Як я вже припустив, ми розглянемо детальніше
це конкретне вимірювання на пізнішому уроці, а поки що
це просто приклад.
Важливим моментом для засвоєння є те, що щось подібне
завжди можливе для будь-якого проекційного вимірювання, тому ми насправді не набуваємо
додаткових можливостей,
вводячи проекційні вимірювання, але це дуже корисна концепція, і ми часто говоритимемо про проекційні вимірювання
у міру продовження серії. Остання частина цього уроку присвячена кільком важливим обмеженням
квантової інформації
та того, що ми можемо робити з quantum circuits.
Перше обмеження, яке, можливо, не так вже й обмеження, а скоріше вироджена, стосується питання глобальних фаз,
яке я згадував трохи раніше. Ось визначення того, що ми маємо на увазі, коли говоримо про глобальну фазу.
Якщо у нас є два вектори
квантового стану Psi і Phi, такі що один з них дорівнює іншому, помноженому на деяке комплексне число альфа,
то ми кажемо, що стани
відрізняються на глобальну фазу, або альтернативно, що вони еквівалентні з точністю до глобальної фази.
Зауваж, що оскільки вектори квантового стану мають евклідову норму, рівну одиниці, єдиний спосіб, щоб це
рівняння могло бути правдивим,
полягає в тому, щоб абсолютне значення
цього комплексного числа дорівнювало одиниці, тому альфа
має лежати на одиничному колі.
Уявімо, що у нас є
два квантових стани, що відрізняються на глобальну фазу, і припустимо, що ми вимірюємо стан Phi
за допомогою вимірювання у стандартному базисі.
Імовірність отримати будь-який результат A задається цим виразом прямо тут, і якщо ми підставимо
альфа помножену на Psi замість Phi,
що ми можемо зробити, тому що ми
припускаємо, що вони рівні, ми отримуємо цю імовірність.
І якщо ми спростимо, використовуючи той факт, що альфа лежить на
комплексному одиничному колі, ми отримаємо цю імовірність.
Пам'ятай, що це імовірність того, що вимірювання Phi дає результат A, але тепер ми бачимо, що
це точно така ж, як і імовірність того, що вимірювання
Psi дає результат A,
тому абсолютно
ніякої різниці немає в імовірностях різних результатів для двох станів.
Схожий аргумент говорить нам більш загально, що для будь-якого проекційного вимірювання імовірності знову однакові.
Тож за допомогою вимірювання ми не можемо
відрізнити два стани, що відрізняються на глобальну фазу, навіть у статистичному сенсі.
Нарешті, якщо ми застосовуємо будь-яку унітарну
операцію до стану Phi, то знову шляхом підстановки те, що ми отримаємо, — це точно
те ж саме комплексне число альфа,
помножене на те, що ми отримаємо, застосовуючи ту ж унітарну
операцію до стану Psi.
Тож два стани все одно
відрізнятимуться на глобальну фазу.
Суть полягає в тому, що два стани абсолютно нерозрізнимі, тому між ними немає жодної
різниці
з точки зору того, що ми могли б
можливо дізнатись про них, виконуючи унітарні
операції та вимірювання, і з цієї причини
ми вважаємо ці два
стани еквівалентними, або якщо хочеш, що це просто два можливо різних
векторних представлення
одного квантового стану.
Як я сказав на
початку обговорення, це в основному виродженість
в тому, як квантові стани описуються векторами квантових станів.
У будь-якому разі, це означає, що ми можемо
просто ігнорувати глобальні фази, так само, як ми ефективно робили, коли описували вимірювання у стандартному базисі
WEBVTT
як проекційні вимірювання. До речі, ця виродженість трапляється лише в спрощеному описі
квантової інформації.
Коли ми описуємо квантові
стани за допомогою матриць щільності, як ми будемо робити в
третьому розділі серії, у нас буде унікальне
матричне представлення
для кожного квантового стану. Питання глобальних фаз
просто не виникає в загальному описі
квантової інформації.
Це ще один привабливий аспект
загального опису квантової інформації,
на який я весь час натякаю, але незалежно від цього, глобальні
фази не турбуватимуть нас,
тому що ми можемо просто скористатись
своєю свободою ігнорувати їх.
Ось дуже швидкий
приклад, просто щоб переконатись, що поняття глобальної фази зрозуміле.
Якщо у нас є мінус-стан і мінус один, помножений на мінус-стан, то ці два стани
відрізняються на глобальну фазу, і зокрема у нас є
альфа рівна мінус одиниці.
З іншого боку, якщо у нас є плюс-стан і мінус-стан, то у нас немає двох станів,
що відрізняються на глобальну фазу.
Це ортогональні вектори, тому вони лінійно незалежні.
Сказати, що два вектори квантового стану відрізняються на глобальну фазу,
еквівалентно тому, що вектори є лінійно залежними,
тому ці вектори
точно не відрізняються на глобальну фазу.
Правда, що єдина відмінність полягає в тому, що цей знак плюс
перетворюється на цей знак мінус, але це те, що ми називаємо
різницею відносних фаз.
Це відрізняється від глобальної фази, тому що ми не
множимо весь вектор на комплексне число.
І це узгоджується з фактом, що ми можемо відрізнити
ці стани, зокрема якщо ми
застосуємо операцію Hadamard
і потім виміряємо, ми побачимо нуль, якщо
стан був плюс-станом, і одиницю, якщо стан був мінус-станом.
Наступне обмеження квантової інформації, яке ми побачимо в цьому уроці,
— це теорема про заборону клонування.
Ось одне формулювання
теореми про заборону клонування, і це конкретне
формулювання теореми є досить конкретним і специфічним,
що полегшить обговорення. Існують інші, більш загальні способи сформулювати теорему про заборону клонування,
але поки що ми зосередимось на цьому.
Ми припускаємо, що у нас є дві системи X та Y, які мають однакову множину класичних станів.
яка складається з
цілих чисел від нуля до D-1, де D щонайменше два.
Насправді не важливо, як називаються класичні стани, але вибравши ці назви, це допоможе зберегти все простим.
Найважливіше тут
те, що є щонайменше два різних класичних
стани, тобто іншими словами, ми не турбуємось про
тривіальний і нецікавий випадок,
коли є лише один класичний стан.
Теорема говорить, що не існує унітарної операції U, яку ми можемо застосувати до X, Y так, щоб якщо ми ініціалізуємо
Y у нульовий стан,
ми ефективно копіюємо або клонуємо
довільні квантові стани X.
Якщо ми подивимось на цей
вираз прямо тут окремо, він говорить, що для всіх виборів вектора квантового стану Psi X,
застосування U до Psi, тензорно перемноженого
на нульовий стан, дає нам Psi тензорно перемножений на Psi, або іншими словами дві
незалежних копії Psi,
ось що означало б, якби ми могли клонувати квантові
стани, і теорема говорить, що це неможливо.
Ти можеш думати про це
в термінах circuits, і теорема говорить, що ти ніколи не зможеш придумати gate або circuit,
що працює так, як ти бачиш тут.
Де одна копія стану Psi надходить разом з колекцією
ініціалізованих qubits і виробляються дві копії Psi.
Ти можеш зробити це для певних
виборів стану Psi, але ти ніколи не можеш придумати
circuit, що працює так для кожного квантового стану Psi,
і ось що говорить теорема.
Цю теорему досить легко довести,
насправді вона по суті зводиться до того факту, що перетворення, яке ми шукаємо, не є лінійним,
але унітарні операції є
лінійними, тому це просто не може працювати.
Ось аргумент трохи детальніше.
Припустимо, що у нас є унітарна операція U, що клонує стани стандартного базису, Ket 0 та Ket один.
Ми знаємо, що класичні
стани нуль і один мають належати до нашої множини класичних станів, тому що D щонайменше два.
Але це означає, з лінійності,
що якщо X перебуває у плюс-стані, що ми можемо записати ось так,
то результат — це ця лінійна комбінація цих двох станів прямо тут.
Однак, це не правильна поведінка. Вимога до U полягає в тому, що U клонує плюс-стан,
що означає, що ми маємо
мати це рівняння прямо тут, яке задовольняється.
Ці два стани не
однакові, тому це не працює, і це все.
Лише кілька додаткових зауважень
щодо теореми про заборону клонування.
По-перше, це формулювання теореми
про заборону клонування є абсолютним у певному сенсі.
Воно просто говорить, що унітарна операція U, що працює точно
ось так, не існує.
Тому ти можеш запитати,
чи існує унітарна операція U, що
робить це наближено відносно деякого способу опису
WEBVTT
наближення до цього твердження. Існують різні
поняття наближення, які могуть бути цікавими,
і ми побачимо кілька
з них у третьому розділі серії, але для цих різних
понять наближення,
існують кількісні формулювання
теореми про заборону клонування, що накладають жорсткі обмеження на те, наскільки добре ти можеш наближено клонувати.
Друге зауваження полягає в тому, що копіювання або клонування станів стандартного базису
безумовно є можливим.
Наприклад, Controlled NOT gate копіює стани стандартного базису qubit.
Це не суперечить
теоремі про заборону клонування. Суть полягає в тому, що клонування в сенсі теореми про заборону клонування вимагає,
щоб це працювало не тільки
для станів стандартного базису,
але для всіх станів.
Controlled NOT gate
звичайно не клонує плюс-стан, наприклад.
І нарешті, варто зазначити, що існує також теорема про заборону клонування для
імовірнісних станів.
Це просто щось таке,
про що люди не говорять і про що не турбуються.
Якщо хтось навмання
вибирає біт, наприклад, за деяким довільним способом
присвоєння імовірностей двом значенням, а
потім передає тобі цей біт,
звичайно ж, ти не можеш отримати дві незалежних вибірки
цього випадкового біта.
Ти просто не знаєш,
які імовірності.
Ти можеш копіювати біт, так само як Controlled NOT
копіює стани стандартного базису, але це не те ж саме, що клонування імовірнісного стану.
У тебе просто немає достатньо
інформації для цього. Який би випадковий біт тобі не дали, він не говорить тобі, якими були
імовірності.
Це просто біт.
Неможливість клонування
імовірнісного стану випливає точно з тих самих міркувань, що й у квантовому випадку.
Клонування є нелінійним процесом, тоді як імовірнісні операції, так само як і унітарні операції, є лінійними.
Тож не дивно,
що ми не можемо клонувати імовірнісний стан, і якимось чином це не так цікаво, як той факт, що ми не можемо
клонувати квантовий стан,
але суть полягає просто в тому, щоб спостерігати, що це не є суто
квантовим явищем.
Остаточне обмеження
квантової інформації, яке ми обговоримо в цьому уроці, полягає в тому, що неможливо абсолютно розрізнити
два квантових стани, які не є ортогональними.
Інший спосіб сказати це
полягає в тому, що якщо два квантових стани можна абсолютно розрізнити, то вони мають бути ортогональними.
Те, що ми маємо на увазі, коли говоримо
про абсолютне розрізнення двох квантових станів Psi та Phi, полягає в тому, що є деякий
спосіб відрізнити їх
без жодного шансу на помилку.
В термінах моделі quantum circuit ми можемо виразити це так,
як ти бачиш тут на екрані.
У нас є деяка унітарна операція U, яка може бути реалізована
як quantum circuit, або ми можемо просто думати про U абстрактно
як унітарну операцію,
і для вхідних даних U приймає або стан Psi, або стан Phi
разом з купою ініціалізованих qubits, про які ти можеш думати як про робочі qubits, що якимось чином допомагають у цьому
процесі розрізнення.
Після застосування U верхній qubit вимірюється відносно вимірювання у стандартному базисі, і ось частина абсолютного
розрізнення.
Якщо вхідний стан був Psi, то вимірювання має
давати результат нуль зі 100% ймовірністю, а якщо
вхідний стан був Phi,
то вимірювання має
давати результат одиниця, знову зі 100% ймовірністю.
Не важливо, якими є
стани цих інших qubits після застосування U.
Важливий лише цей один біт, що ми отримуємо з вимірювання, тому що саме він говорить нам, з якого з двох станів ми почали.
Для деяких виборів станів Psi та Phi буде можливо виконати абсолютне розрізнення на кшталт
цього, а для інших — ні.
І те, що ми спостерігатимемо, полягає в тому, що
якщо це можливо зробити, то Psi та Phi мають
бути ортогональними станами,
і це означає, що якщо Phi та
Psi не є ортогональними, ти не можеш абсолютно розрізнити їх.
Тож давай подивимось, чому абсолютне розрізнення тягне за собою ортогональність.
Почнемо з запису двох рівнянь, що виражають те, що виражають ці
дві діаграми.
Якщо ми думаємо про квантовий стан, який ми отримуємо після застосування U до
купи ініціалізованих qubits разом зі станом Psi,
ми бачимо, що він має
мати таку форму прямо тут, де Pi zero — деякий вектор квантового стану, що представляє стан
всіх цих qubits,
крім верхнього. Ми не маємо жодної інформації
про цей квантовий стан Pi zero, він може бути будь-яким,
але ми знаємо, що весь
стан має виглядати так, тому що це єдиний
спосіб гарантувати, що вимірювання дасть
результат нуль зі 100% ймовірністю.
І ми маємо аналогічне
рівняння для другого.
Цього разу верхній qubit
має бути в одиничному стані, і аналогічно Pi zero, стан
Pi один може бути будь-яким.
І крім того, що ми не маємо
жодної інформації про Pi один, ми також нічого не знаємо
про зв'язок між Pi zero та Pi один.
Все, що ми знаємо, — це те, що це просто два
довільних квантових стани.
WEBVTT
Далі ми можемо
помножити обидві сторони цих рівнянь
з обох сторін на U кинджал, тобто спряжену транспоновану U.
І якщо ми це зробимо, отримаємо два рівняння,
що ти бачиш тут.
Ми використовуємо той факт, що U кинджал помножена на U є матрицею тотожності.
Ось чому ми не бачимо U або U кинджал на лівій стороні жодного рівняння.
І тепер ми можемо розглянути скалярний добуток між Psi та Phi.
Він такий самий, як скалярний
добуток Psi та Phi, помножений на скалярний
добуток стану L zero з самим собою,
тому що скалярний добуток
будь-якого стану з самим собою дорівнює одиниці, і це включає стан L zero.
І тепер, якщо ми подивимось на наші два рівняння, ми бачимо, що цей вираз тут дорівнює скалярному добутку векторів,
представлених двома рівняннями. І зокрема, це скалярний добуток між лівими
сторонами цих рівнянь.
Тому ми рівною мірою можемо
виразити цей скалярний добуток як скалярний добуток векторів, представлених правими
сторонами цих рівнянь,
тому що ліва сторона дорівнює правій стороні в обох рівняннях.
Тож ми отримуємо цей вираз прямо тут, що є скалярним добутком
двох правих сторін рівнянь, або еквівалентно,
це спряжена транспонована першого, помножена на друге.
U помножена на U кинджал дорівнює
матриці тотожності, тому що U є унітарною, і тому вона зникає.
І ми можемо спростити трохи, щоб отримати добуток
цих скалярних добутків.
Тепер пам'ятай, що ми нічого не знаємо про зв'язок
між Pi zero та Pi один, тому ми не знаємо, яким є
їх скалярний добуток.
Це загадка для нас. Але що б це не було, ми множимо його на скалярний добуток Ket 0 та Ket один, який дорівнює нулю.
Тому кінцевий результат полягає в тому, що
ми отримуємо значення нуль, але це те, що ми хотіли показати, — скалярний добуток між
Psi та Phi дорівнює нулю.
Тож два стани є ортогональними.
Тож не витрачай час, намагаючись
абсолютно розрізнити два неортогональних квантових
стани, ти просто не можеш цього зробити.
Існує зворотне до
твердження, яке ми щойно довели, — що ортогональні квантові стани завжди можна абсолютно розрізнити,
і це не так важко
побачити, якщо ми скористаємось фактом, який я згадував раніше в уроці.
Зокрема, якщо Psi та
Phi є ортогональними станами, то одне, що ми можемо зробити, — це вибрати будь-яку унітарну матрицю U,
перші два стовпці якої
є цими двома станами.
Ми знаємо, що це завжди
можливо, і не важливо
для цього завдання, як саме вибрано цю унітарну матрицю.
Все, що важливо, — це те, що це перші два стовпці.
Нам не потрібні додаткові qubits. Якщо ми просто застосуємо U до
двох можливих станів, то отримаємо ці
два можливих результати.
І якщо ми виміряємо найверхніший qubit, який пам'ятай є найправішим qubit, то отримаємо нуль або одиницю
залежно від того, з якого стану ми почали.
Альтернативно, ми можемо розглянути
проекційне вимірювання з результатами від нуля до одиниці,
визначене так, як ти бачиш тут.
У цьому випадку вимірювання
насправді залежить лише від Psi.
Це вимірювання абсолютно
розрізняє Psi від будь-якого стану, що ортогональний Psi.
Якщо ми вимірюємо Psi відносно цього проекційного вимірювання, то отримаємо результат
нуль з імовірністю один, як ці рівняння показують.
І для будь-якого стану Phi,
що ортогональний Psi, ми отримаємо результат
одиниця з імовірністю один.
Я не буду деталізувати
ці обчислення, але якщо тобі цікаво, я заохочую тебе пройти
через деталі самостійно.
І це кінець третього уроку. Ми охопили багато
матеріалу в цьому уроці, включаючи quantum circuits,
скалярні добутки та ортонормальність, проекції та проекційні вимірювання, той факт, що глобальні фази не мають значення,
теорему про заборону клонування та той факт, що неортогональні стани не можна абсолютно розрізнити, тоді як ортогональні — можна.
Сподіваюсь, ти приєднаєшся до мене на
четвертому уроці незабаром, який є останнім уроком у
першому розділі серії.
У четвертому уроці ми поговоримо про три
дуже важливих приклади: телепортацію, надщільне кодування,
та нерівність CHSH або гру CHSH, як її іноді називають.
До зустрічі,